hello everybody welcome to the david
pakman show i'm producer pat ford
filling in for david today as he
continues his paternity leave of course
yesterday we had tdps correspondent luke
beasley fill in for david he did an
excellent job he really set the bar high
so we'll see if i'll be able to meet
that threshold today for you and then
the rest of the week we're still trying
to figure out but i can assure you that
david will be back before you know it
let's start things off today by talking
about day 4 of the january 6th hearings
which took place yesterday and the theme
of the day was focusing on how trump
pressured state level officials mostly
republicans mind you to overturn the
election results there was testimony
from three republican election officials
georgia secretary of state brad
rappensberger who at this point were all
very familiar with his deputy gabe
sterling and arizona house of
representative speaker rusty bowers they
were all pressured to do trump's bidding
in what i would argue was criminal
influence by the former president but
we'll see if the biden justice
department and merrick garland agree
even though these three refused to go
along with trump's wishes the then
president would not take no for an
answer and he kept harassing them during
the hearing we learned that members of
congress also tried pressuring these
officials including representative andy
biggs from arizona who called rusty
bowers on the morning of january 6th
asking him to support decertification of
the electoral votes all three of these
people testifying raffensberger sterling
and bowers received threats from trump
supporters after they refused to go
along with the plot to decertify and
send fake electors to various state
houses who would then send the electoral
votes to congress perhaps the most
emotional part of the day was when rusty
bowers explained the protests going on
at his home as all this was going on and
even up until now
apparently protesters were bothering his
gravely ill daughter threatening the
family levying baseless accusations
against him that he's a pedophile let's
play uh the moment from the hearings
that was perhaps the most emotional in
all of yesterday
as others in the videos have mentioned
we received
my secretaries would say
in excess of 20 000 emails and
tens of thousands of voicemails and
texts
which
saturated our offices and we are unable
to work
at least communicate
but at home
up till even recently
it is the new
pattern or a pattern in our lives to
worry what will happen on saturdays
because we
have various groups come by
and
they have had
um
video panel trucks with videos of me
proclaiming me to be a pedophile and a
pervert and a corrupt and
politician
and
blaring
uh
loudspeakers in my neighborhood
and
leaving literature both on my
property but arguing and threatening
with neighbors
and with myself
i don't know if i should name groups but
there was a one gentleman that had the
three bars on his chest and he had a
pistol
and was threatening my neighbor not with
the pistol but just vocally
when i saw the gun i knew i had to get
close
and
at the same time
on some of these
we had
a daughter who was gravely ill
who was upset
by
what was happening outside
and my wife that
was a valiant person very
very strong
quiet
very strong woman
so it was disturbing
it was disturbing bowers went on to read
an entry he wrote in his journal around
this time wherein he said quote i do not
want to be a winner by cheating i will
not play with the laws i swore
allegiance to and that really used to be
what america was all about that
republicans and democrats could argue
and try to win as many votes as they
could but then once you have the
election and the votes are counted
that's it you tally it up the loser
concedes to the winner the winner takes
office and the loser has every
opportunity to run again the next time
if they want to but you don't parade
around the country saying that it was
all rigged and that you really won and
trying to overturn election results by
pressuring officials and all this stuff
we had this long tradition of doing it
right or mostly right in this country up
until donald trump in the 2020 election
in addition to this moment uh
raffensberger spoke about when trump
pressured him on that famous phone call
to find the quote 11 780 votes and
sterling spoke about how he in real time
debunked rudy giuliani's lies about
georgia election officials supposedly
counting fake votes for biden and trump
despite the fact that sterling had
debunked those claims decided to amplify
the claims nonetheless so one would
maybe look at this hearing and think
that okay maybe trump supporters could
be convinced by this because the
accounts and these testimonies are
coming from republicans so they have no
agenda here right they're not democrats
they're not just trying to say that
biden won for
political purposes or anything like that
however in the trumpist's eyes these
people are rhinos they're not true
republicans because they're not true
trump supporters so they don't count
right they can be put aside and
discounted so you know these people are
largely too far gone maybe we just
shouldn't try to focus too much on
concerning ourselves with trying to
convince them and instead maybe we
should look at these hearings as a
possible way to get towards pressuring
the biden justice department and
attorney general merrick garlands to
press charges against the former
president but given that we have this
long tradition of not prosecuting former
presidents i'm personally not going to
hold my breath but it's still good to
learn all the different things that
we're learning about because of these
january 6th hearings donald trump knew
that he lost the 2020 election to joe
biden and admitted as much to a white
house aide in november of 2020. this
actually could have implications having
to do with whether he's going to get
charged as a result of the january 6th
hearings or in that investigation that's
going on currently in georgia because it
goes to the former president's intent
which is an important element if you're
trying to show that he was willingly
deceiving the american people the aid is
alissa faith griffin who worked as the
white house director of strategic
communications she went on cnn's state
of the union with dana bash and said the
following one of the questions that
we've been asking
since these hearings started is whether
or not the committee can prove intent
whether the president intentionally
uh tried to overturn the election
knowing that he actually lost
he told you in november of 2020 that he
lost when you were working in the white
house he admitted he blurted out
watching joe biden on tv can you believe
i lost to this guy and he actually
admitted in a press conference when he
was speaking to the um about coronavirus
in the press briefing room he actually
slipped and kind of admitted that joe
biden won i think intent is going to be
hard i'm not of the mind that this is
going to take down donald trump in a
legal sort of way but i do think it's
going to inform the public about a man
who lost and couldn't do what we've done
for the entirety of our history which is
you know allow a peaceful transition of
power and allow who the voters elected
to step into office can you believe i
lost the election to this guy is
allegedly the quote and as elissa faith
griffin and dana bash point out you have
a much stronger case of criminal intent
if trump is privately accepting the fact
that he lost the election fairly and
squarely while at the same time going
out in public and saying that it was
rigged and it was stolen from him and
all these things but there's a couple of
reasons why i don't think that this
quote in this account make it a slam
dunk case by any means that trump had
any sort of criminal intent for one
you're relying on the word of a former
aide which although i'm sure she's
credible and you could probably get her
to cooperate with an investigation and
testify in all these different things
it's not on video it's not like we have
the audio recording of donald trump
saying this and as far as we know it's
not corroborated by other sources so
that's one she referenced him admitting
he lost in another instance during that
coronavirus press briefing but it could
have been one of those slip of the
tongue type of things like sometimes he
would give this half-hearted concession
where he'd say something like a new
administration will soon be taking over
which is just sort of accepting the fact
that someone else is going to be taking
over the role as president without
accepting that he just lost the election
fairly so it's a little bit different
there number two and i think this is
more important i'm of the belief that as
the election results were pouring in and
biden was declared the winner a couple
days after the 2020 election trump knew
that he lost and he knew that he simply
didn't get the votes that he needed to
win i don't think that initially he was
actually a believer in the voter fraud
stuff that he was talking about but then
as the weeks and months went on my sense
at least is that he actually did start
to believe it we suspect without being
the ones to diagnose him or anything
like that that donald trump has
narcissistic personality disorder or
something similar to it so he was just
unable to reconcile the fact that he
lost because he thinks so highly of
himself right it's this cognitive
dissonance that he couldn't get beyond
and so the way that he decided to deal
with it was slowly but surely convincing
himself that he actually won the
election and surrounding himself like
with people like mike lindell and sydney
powell and rudy giuliani and michael
flynn who are telling him that oh no no
no you won and he was eventually willing
to suspend reality suspend disbelief and
just put aside his better judgment and
accept it because that went into the the
narrative that he was trying to arrive
at at the entire time which is that
actually he did win the election that's
my sense of it all and if it really is
the case that donald trump operates in
that way it's going to be hard to show
criminal intent because ultimately he
really did believe the things that he
was talking about and that makes it all
the more difficult so i do believe that
what alyssa faith griffin said is true i
also suspect that that was early on in
the process and by now he's changed his
mind and he really does think that he
won we're going to be back with you
after the break stay tuned everyone
welcome back to the david pakman show
i'm producer pat ford filling in for
david today as he continues his
paternity leave we're now finding out
more having to do with the uvalde
shooting that took place a few weeks ago
and specifically the police department's
failed response to it we're now finding
out that they're working with a private
law firm to prevent the release of
details to the public as to what exactly
they were doing as a gunman was inside
rob elementary school murdering 19
children and two teachers we already
knew that their story had changed a
bunch and we knew that they hesitated
there was a dispute over when exactly
they arrived and whether they confronted
the shooter at the door whether that
door was propped open by a teacher but
at the very least it was clear from
early on that they didn't follow
protocol that they waited and waited and
they didn't want to go into the school
out of fear for their own lives and that
they even went so far as to hold back
parents who were trying to go in and
save their kids knowing that the cops
weren't going to do anything for them in
addition we found out this week that
cops were in the hallway of the school
but refused to advance even though they
certainly had the proper equipment the
rifles and the guards and the shields
and everything that you would need to
confront the shooter and they were also
spending spending a bunch of time trying
to find a key to the classroom that the
shooter was hiding in even though the
door was unlocked the entire time so
they didn't need a key
so now the police department wants to
make sure nothing more gets out the
public records they're trying to hide
which include the body camera footage
the photos 911 calls emails text
messages they're trying to hide all of
it a letter from the city to texas
attorney general ken paxton says that
the department doesn't want to release
the information because for one it's
being sued which is somewhat
understandable i guess but also because
it includes highly embarrassing
information and that the info is not of
legitimate concern to the public so how
brazen can they be they're out now
admitting that what's in the documents
is embarrassing meaning that they did
wrong that they knew that they did wrong
and that it's just not important
apparently for the public to learn about
even though this is a matter of having
to do with the deaths of 21 people in
the community many of them little kids
and you're going to say that it's of no
concern to the public how can you get
away with saying something like that the
city and its police department argue it
should be exempted from releasing police
officer training guides police policy
and procedure manuals shift change
schedules security details and
blueprints of secured facilities because
these could be used to decipher methods
techniques and strategies for preventing
and predicting crime well okay to some
degree i understand this one but clearly
whatever methods techniques and
strategies they had ahead of this mass
shooting they either didn't work or they
didn't follow them they chose not to use
them and so it would be nice to review
the process and see how we could go
about changing it so this is going to be
a travesty if they're allowed to block
the documents from public view
especially because they've already been
caught in so many lies and the public
has a right to know about this stuff
right because it's their tax dollars
that were being spent and it was their
community that was ultimately hurt by
all of this and hurt by their failed
response and this is a situation that
probably should lead to some criminal
charges i'm not saying that you should
charge the entire police department but
certainly the officers who were there
who had the opportunity to go in and
decided not to many of them should be
charged with child neglect that's what
happened to that officer in parkland who
refused to go into the school that
should probably happen to many of the
officers who were on scene there and at
the very least
many of those cops should be losing
their jobs because not only did those
uvalde police officers fail those 21
victims and their families not only did
they fail the uvalde community they also
failed society at large like the public
needs to be able to trust that if s hits
the fan the cops are going to be there
around the corner to protect them that's
why police officers get the respect and
the reverence that they do among most
people in the country because they're
believed to be putting their lives on
the line you can't have a situation
where the community views cops as just
the people who are out there giving
traffic tickets or breaking up
high school parties acting like tough
guys and so doing
but then not step in when a situation
like this really calls for it really
calls for police attention so let's
cross our fingers and hope that this
effort to block the body cam footage and
the text and all the other relevant
information isn't successful because the
public deserves to know about this right
and these cops need to be held
accountable for their dereliction of
duty not just in response to this
specific shooting and the 21 victims but
also for the ramifications that it has
for society at large there's a
right-wing radio host named wayne allen
root and he actually used to come on the
show a few years back he would have
these interesting back and forths with
david but over the past year or so he's
been most famous for being adamant in
this idea that donald trump should run
for speaker of the house if indeed
republicans take control of congress
after the 2022 midterms what the idea
there being that donald trump can be the
one to torpedo biden's legislative
agenda and perhaps be the ones who
oversee impeachment proceedings if
republicans decide to impeach joe biden
for whatever reason they decide to come
up with keep in mind that in order to be
the speaker of the house you don't
actually have to be a member of congress
so it's not like trump would have to run
for a house seat he could just be
elected by the majority of the body if
republicans take control and while
traditionally the speaker of the house
is a member of congress themselves they
don't actually have to be so a while ago
root came up with this idea he was
interviewing trump and he was telling
him all about it and trump said you know
that's really interesting no one's ever
brought that to my attention before i'll
have to consider it and it seems like at
this point trump just doesn't want to do
it either because it would be too much
work or it's just not the top job in
government so
he just doesn't want to pay any mind to
it so this prompted wayne allen root to
ask donald trump about whether that
means trump supports kevin mccarthy to
be house speaker if republicans take
control of congress and trump didn't
want to say that he necessarily supports
kevin mccarthy let's uh take a look at
this clip because it really is
interesting and it has to do with this
narrative having to do with republican
infighting you know i was the guy who
first brought up the idea of you running
for speaker of the house if we win
in november you like the idea but you
never acted on it and you've now
endorsed mccarthy for speaker of the
house why don't you consider running no
you haven't no i endorsed him in his
race but i haven't endorsed anybody for
speech okay so why not consider now
that's super interesting because of
course we know from that leaked audio
that came out a few weeks ago that right
after the january 6 attacks kevin
mccarthy was fed up with donald trump he
said that he was ready to move on from
him which makes total sense because
mccarthy's life was put in danger that
day as were the lives of other members
of congress and mike pence and
congressional staff and capitol police
but then it turned out that a few days
later mccarthy saw the polling and he
realized that republican voters were not
so ready to move on from donald trump in
fact many of them liked the insurrection
so mccarthy and the rest of the gop they
had to do a 180 and go back to groveling
at the feet of trump so this means that
trump who still has by all accounts a
hold of the republican party if he
decides to endorse someone else for
house speaker he's probably going to get
his way and mccarthy won't have much to
say about it but also donald trump went
on to cite a different reason for why
he's upset with kevin mccarthy and i
found this one really interesting let's
take a look at this we have some great
warriors jim jordan the whole group jim
banks we have some very good people that
you know fight very very hard
unfortunately a bad decision was made
this this committee was a bad decision
not to have representation on that
committee that was a very very
uh foolish decision right because uh you
know they try and pretend like they're
legit and only when you get into the
inner workings you say what kind of a
thing is this it's just a one-sided
witch hunt donald trump is mad at kevin
mccarthy for not making the select
committee investigating january 6th
bipartisan how about that and of course
you do have liz cheney and adam
kinzinger on the committee but they can
just be written off as anti-trump rhinos
by trump and his supporters so
apparently they don't really count this
is incredible to hear though because
when the idea of the committee was first
proposed mccarthy and republican
leadership they were actually on board
with the idea of investigating january
6th and the lead up to it making it a
truly bipartisan panel because they too
were affected by what took place at the
capitol that day but then as time went
on they decided it would be too
politically risky because it would make
donald trump look bad it would make the
right look bad and so they just decided
we as a party are going to move on from
january 6th and we're not going to have
our members serve on this panel aside
from kenzinger and cheney who we can't
control now that democrats along with
these two republicans have moved on and
said okay we're just going to do it
without you then donald trump comes out
and says why don't we have republicans
on the panel why don't we have
representation mccarthy made a mistake
here so that really is donald trump for
you if you're working for donald trump
or if you're in a position where you're
expected to be loyal to donald trump
you're damned if you do and you damn to
if you don't because there's just no
satisfying this guy and if you do things
right and you're working with him well
trump's just going to take all the
credit for it but if things go wrong you
best believe that you're going to
receive the blame and that's exactly the
situation that mccarthy has found
himself in so that may ultimately cost
him the speakership next year and it's
kind of funny to sit back and watch
friend of the show crystal ball was on
bill maher's real time show over the
weekend and she absolutely schooled him
on a number of topics including whether
biden is too far left and whether
democrats are to blame for inflation and
turmoil going on in the stock market
right now now bill maher he's for sure a
liberal but he's no progressive i think
we can say like in the 2020 democratic
primaries when there were all these
different candidates to choose from the
person that he settled on was amy
klobuchar of all people so that's the
kind of democrat that he is and bill
maher will often criticize the left for
being too woke and too extreme and say
that the left is too thin skinned in all
these different things crystal ball is a
co-host on breaking points with sauger
and jetty and she also has a podcast
with kyle kalinski called crystal kyle
and friends she is a true progressive by
all accounts we can definitely say that
for sure and she absolutely took bill to
task when he tried to do the i'm on the
left but i criticized the far left
routine so here are the two debating
whether biden's approval numbers tanked
because he went too far to the left
here's my question about joe biden for
you two
has he pandered to the far left a
too much
b too little
not at all
because aoc would say not at all well if
you other people would say he pandered
way too much to the phone you look at
the trajectory of his presidency at the
beginning of his presidency he did some
of the things that myself as a person on
the left would like him to see passes
the covet relief bill and lo and behold
he had very high approval ratings you're
not always on the left then
i am on the left
left there's the populist economic left
and then there's the woke left these are
two separate in any case let's talk
about what he's actually done so in the
beginning of the administration he
passes that very high approval rating
doing extraordinarily well when he puts
out the left agenda and build back
better and then it fails and he stops
delivering for the american people
explaining that's when he finished by
the left agenda in the billboard well
there's universal pre-campaign it's not
everything that i would want right no
medicare for all there's no green new
deal but you had universal pre-k you had
affordable child care you had elder care
you had an expansion of medicare you had
things that would have delivered for the
american people
that falls apart partly because of
mansion cinema parliament to all of that
that falls apart and since now the
american people are feeling incredible
pain with inflation and gas prices and
unable to put food on the table and put
gas in the car
and he's basically
seeded the ground and said ah there's
not much i can do i just hope the fed
gets this under control
yeah the approval ratings have fallen
off a cliff that's nothing to do with
the left i wish the left had more power
in fact i think the left is the only
part of the political spectrum that has
offered anything to deal with inflation
gas prices in the current economic
situation that doesn't just involve hey
let's trigger a recession and kill
people's wages this is the correct
assessment from crystal ball here joe
biden was super popular at the beginning
of his presidency because he was able to
get things done and he had an approval
rating of something like 55 to 60
percent as time has gone on he hasn't
been able to get things passed and so
he's starting to look feckless and
unable to respond to some of the
challenges that we as a country are
facing and so his approval numbers have
gone down accordingly and notice how
bill steps in there and tries to reset
by saying crystal you have to slow down
you have to be more clear and concise as
if what she was saying wasn't already
super clear and concise and uh he does
this later on it's just like a
rhetorical crutch that he's using here
because he realizes that he's outmatched
when it comes to the facts next they're
discussing inflation and the reasons for
it and bill just has a difficult time
recounting the historical events of the
past couple of years let's roll that
part of this inflationary problem is
because we put too much money into the
economy there's way too much government
spending and that's why we have
inflation so that's a large part of that
economics
we have this thing called a pandemic we
had a supply chain crisis and oh by the
way
it played a role
i knew a little bit of money they got
more than we spent in world war ii so
you don't act like the past
hold on don't act like you said don't
act don't act like we had to react to
the pandemic exactly the way we did we
hacked it we had to spend six okay but
how about
that the federal reserve shot at wall
street for some reason people don't get
upset about that
fueled the trillions of dollars the
federal reserve shot at wall street
the stock market in the bond market no
one gets upset about that even though
that was a massive i don't know what
you're talking about what do you mean
shot at wall street when are we talking
about it we're talking about buying
assets buying stocks buying bonds buying
treasury bills so that they expand the
balance sheet this is during the crisis
the chronovirus crisis when the stock
market crashed that is what the fed did
they went into action they shot but the
stock market didn't crash during now
it's crashing it's crashing now it
crashed and the fed came in and
backstopped it that's what happened it
crashed and we never heard about it no
it crashed go back and look at it it
fell off a cliff treasury bond market
stopped functioning and the fed took
extraordinary action it's never taken in
history
someone somehow nobody gets upset about
the rich people who got tons of money
and tons of support way more than
working-class people did oh my god
people were able to feed their kids and
they had a little bit of money in their
bank accounts it was the worst thing in
the world that is one small part of the
inflation story and is by the way not
the only thing that we can deal with to
get out of this mess so once again
there's that rhetorical crush that bill
uses by saying shot at i don't
understand what you mean shot at you
have to explain what you mean by this
term as if we don't all understand what
crystal is saying when she says shot at
she means pumped up infused added to but
bill has to get super pedantic and focus
on this one term because he's losing the
exchange and he recognizes that and then
he doesn't remember somehow how the
stock market crashed at the very
beginning of the coveted pandemic it
certainly did uh the major indices
plunged about 30 to 40 percent at the
start of the pandemic before quickly
bouncing back because of yes the federal
reserve announcing their commitment to
bailing out companies and buying up
debts now even though bill should know
about this because he follows news and
politics and he does a show about news
and politics and you'd think he would be
up on world events i kind of give him
credit in a weird way for
not remembering that the stock market
crashed at the beginning of the pandemic
because bill is obviously a very
well-off person and so he most likely
has a bunch of money in the stock market
so he must have lost a ton of money at
the very beginning of the pandemic
before yes quickly gaining it all back
so you'd think that like many other rich
people he would have been freaking out
at the very beginning of the pandemic
for losing all that money but apparently
it didn't phase him so to some degree i
think that makes him look good in my
opinion but the broader point is the one
that crystal made which is that when the
government bails out the stock and the
bond markets that's just solid economics
right you know that's just what we're
supposed to do as a country but then
when money is given to the middle class
and the working class in the form of
unemployment checks and stimulus checks
and child tax credits that's blamed for
tanking the economy and we sure as hell
can never do that again so excellent job
there by crystal and i kind of get the
sense that maybe she won't be invited
back on bill maher's show anytime soon
because she really made him look bad
welcome back to the show so we're still
awaiting a number of crucial decisions
from the supreme court and with their
term expected to come to an end at the
end of june it's shaping up to be a wild
week in politics obviously the big one
on everyone's minds right now is the
abortion rights decision we believe that
the court is expected to overturn roe
versus wade in the coming days or weeks
but there's also some other important
decisions upcoming that i thought that
it would bring to your attention
including on issues like environmental
protection gun control and the trump era
remain in mexico policy so let's go
through them starting with the big one
abortion dobbs versus jackson women's
health organization that's the name of
the case that's expected to be decided
on and the policy that makes abortion
banned in mississippi after 15 weeks
outside of limited circumstances like
medical emergencies we know that based
on the leaked draft opinion written by
justice samuel alito back in february
that it's believed that the court will
rule in favor of the mississippi law and
go broader to throw out the 50 years of
precedent that is roe versus wade and
the 30 year old casey versus planned
parenthood decision there is hope among
progressives that between when this
draft was written and now that chief
justice john roberts was able to pick
off one or two conservative members of
the court and get them to change their
mind but given how much of a hot button
political topic this is and how
republicans have tried for decades to
overturn roe versus wade i wouldn't hold
my breath for it right it seems like roe
vs wade likely will be overturned but
hopefully i'm proven wrong the question
then will be if roe vs wade is
overturned will we see this large public
outrage and will this get a lot of
attention because maybe you can argue
you've already let the air out of the
balloon because we found out about this
leaked decision back in may so is this
already expected will there not be that
much backlash we'll just have to wait
and see or hopefully we don't wait and
see because it doesn't end up actually
happening but we'll find out soon
there's also this case in the docket
called west virginia versus
environmental protection agency which is
all about the federal government's
ability to create environmental
regulations a bunch of republican
attorneys general from states with a big
fossil fuel industry presence like west
virginia argue that the epa and other
executive branch agencies should not be
allowed to set their own rules and
regulations in place when it comes to
things like regulating greenhouse gas
emissions and that only congress should
be allowed to do that another one of
these examples of republicans waiting
and waiting until they had a
conservative majority in the court to
bring up these issues to the high court
and now that they have that majority
they want to strike while the iron is
hot so we'll see how that ruling goes
there's also a gun control measure uh
case called new york state rifle and
pistol association versus bruin which is
the biggest gun case that the court has
ruled on since the dc versus heller case
back in 2008 that decision has to do
with whether an individual has the right
to have a gun inside their home this
case has to do with whether a person has
the right to have a gun outside of their
home new york as we know has very strict
gun control measures and citizens have
to show a proper cause in order to get a
concealed carry permit so if this case
goes in the right wing's favor we may
see many of these gun control measures
across the states be overturned
effectively and maybe concealed carry
will be
the law across the land we'll just have
to find out and obviously that has big
implications in the wake of the mass
shootings in buffalo and valdez and then
finally we have biden versus texas which
is over the immigration policy known as
remain in mexico that requires people
seeking asylum to stay in mexico while
they await their hearings which can
often be very dangerous for them and
then they're often subject to the will
of mexican officials and they have to
wait for months or years up until their
court date in the u.s comes up
and so the buying administration has
tried twice to end the policy but lower
courts have rescinded it meaning that
it's now going up to the supreme court
so we'll soon find out the ruling on
this one there's also another eight or
so decisions upcoming so a lot to be had
soon and uh you know this kind of goes
back to the conversation we often have
about how elections have consequences
because of course republican presidents
over the years have been able to put
justices on the court that get approved
by a largely republican senate and you
know if we had uh democratic presidents
and senators over the years we probably
would have more left-wing justices and
we wouldn't be in the mess that we're in
right now it looks like a lot of these
decisions are not going to go in our
favor hopefully some of them do though
and we'll just have to wait and see but
we'll probably know soon and that's the
latest on the supreme court and their
upcoming decisions as we await the
official supreme court decision on
abortion rights red states across the
country are continuing to pass
restrictive abortion measures with the
idea that they can be challenged up to
the high court or that they can just be
outright allowed to stand if and when
roe versus wade is overturned the latest
such example comes from louisiana with a
bill that they have passed governor john
bel edwards who is a democrat mind you
but a so-called pro-life democrat uh he
has signed into law senate bill 342
which is a trigger law that will do away
with abortion in almost all
circumstances it does carve out
exceptions for medical futility and
ectopic pregnancies but it does not
carve out exceptions for rape and incest
there's also a penalty in there for
abortion providers with um sentences
ranging anywhere from 10 to 15 years in
prison luckily there is no criminal
penalty for women who seek and get
abortions in the state as has been the
trend in many of these bills in red
states across the country lately the
governor said that he wishes that there
was an exception for rape and incest but
he decided to sign the bill into law
anyway he explained this in a statement
saying quote i am pro-life and have
never hidden from that fact this does
not belie my belief that there should be
an exception to the prohibition on
abortion for victims of rape and incest
however vetoing senate bill 342 would
not accomplish that end in fact vetoing
senate bill 342 would leave fewer
exceptions in place than if the bill
becomes law and would further confuse
whether pregnancy begins at
fertilization or
implantation for these reasons i have
signed senate bill 342 into law now i
thought that this story offered an
opportunity to talk about some of the
leaps in logic when it comes to the
right-wing view on abortion particularly
when it comes to not prosecuting women
who have abortions and also when it
comes to carving out exceptions for rape
and incest so starting with the first
one most republicans at this point don't
want to see women prosecuted who have
abortions they may want to prosecute the
medical providers but not the women
themselves and to me that doesn't really
make sense given their logic right
because if you buy into this idea that
abortion is murder well shouldn't you
hold accountable not only the person
who's actually doing the murder but also
the person who called the hit like if in
this current society as things are not
only does a hitman get in trouble and
get prosecuted if they kill someone also
the person that ordered the hit gets in
trouble as well so why wouldn't the same
be true for
a case having to do with an abortion
also the leap in logic when it comes to
republicans on this issue has to do with
the rape and incest thing because they
argue that life begins at conception all
life is sacred god has a plan for
everyone why would that not apply to a
woman who gets raped now certainly i
don't think she should have to carry a
baby to term and have that be a constant
reminder of the tragic event that
happened to her but many of these
republicans think that there should be
these exceptions carved out and to me it
doesn't really seem to make sense if the
whole reason that they're against
abortion is because they believe that
life begins at conception and they
believe that it's murder to kill a baby
in the womb so given their logic on
these different things to me it just
doesn't make all that much sense and
sadly no longer are these conversations
hypothetical merely because now we're
starting to see abortion get banned in
states across the country certainly
that's going to be the case if roe vs
wade is indeed overturned these trigger
laws are going to get enacted like this
one in louisiana and we're going to have
to have these conversations and to my
understanding republicans simply aren't
ready to have them so that's the latest
on one of these abortion bills that are
being passed in a red state and i'm sure
there are more to come
welcome back to the show producer pat
ford filling in for david today as he
continues his paternity leave so joe
biden is waiting whether to set in place
a gas tax holiday in response to the
ballooning gas prices which have
actually come down a little bit in
recent days and i'll get to that in a
second but as i'm sure many of you know
there's a federal gasoline tax it's 18.3
cents per gallon and the money goes
towards restoring roads and bridges all
across the country but with prices of
gasoline at around five dollars a gallon
right now there's this idea floating
that maybe it would be a good idea to
provide temporary relief to americans
who are feeling it at the pump and
suspend the gas tax the decision is
supposed to come from the joe biden
administration at the end of the week
however you really need congress to
enact this biden said that he is also
weighing whether to send americans gas
rebate cards saying that that's part of
what they're considering and that's part
of the operation previously the
administration said that it would be too
difficult to put in place a system for
gas rebate cards but now they're taking
another look at it when it comes to the
gas tax holiday i get the sense that if
joe biden wants it the democrats are
going to go along with it and he'll be
able to get the votes although you know
democrats are often cautious about doing
anything that will do away with uh you
know funds for things like
infrastructure the question is would
republicans go along with it though
because
more than they want to actually fix
these issues surrounding inflation and
high gas prices and the like they want
to have something to attack joe biden on
so they're totally happy in my opinion
seeing gas prices go up and up and up
because it gives them a greater chance
possibly of winning in the midterms so
maybe they'll oppose joe biden's tax
holiday idea and then turn around and
blame him for the high gas prices the
aaa national average for a gallon of
gasoline right now is down to 4.96 which
is still exceptionally high but it's
down from five dollars and two cents a
week or so ago so this could be a sign
that we've reached the peak could be a
sign that gas prices are going to
trickle down from here on but it's still
too early to say and then you think okay
if we move towards suspending the
federal gas tax we're looking at an
average of uh you know
4.78 cents per gallon or so that does
sound a lot better but is it going to
make a material difference for the
average american because let's say right
now it costs say 80 bucks to fill up
your tank
well now it's going to go down about
three dollars it'll be 77 dollars to
fill up your tank which okay i get it
for the average people out there just
trying to make ends meet it could make
some difference right but i think for
the most part this is more about
politics it's more about uh making it so
that joe biden looks like he's trying to
actually solve the issue and for some
americans it just helps um sort of at
the psychological level that if you
drive by the gas station that the
numbers are going down a little bit that
is now four dollars and 87 cents instead
of five dollars that helps a little bit
right
we have the same conversation whenever
we talk about the idea of taking more
oil out of the strategic petroleum
reserve that it can do some good right
but at the end of the day it's only
going to save you about 10 cents a
gallon 20 cents a gallon so is that
going to be a substantial difference for
most americans and obviously a big
factor in the high price of gas right
now isn't just the pandemic recovery
and inflation and putin's war on ukraine
is also greed from the oil and gas
companies which are experiencing record
profits at the moment joe biden said
about this uh that he's going to be
speaking with the oil and gas ceos
members of his administration
specifically will so they can get an
explanation as to how they're able to
make 35 billion dollars in the first
quarter of the year while the average
american is struggling so that's the
latest on gas prices they are coming
down a little bit but they would come
down quite a bit deal more if joe biden
and the democrats and the rest of
congress decide to suspend the gas tax a
former gas station manager in california
is out of a job right now after making
the mistake of selling premium gasoline
for 69 cents a gallon instead of
6.99 a gallon the man in question is
named john cezanna and he worked at a
shell station in rancho cordova
california once customers realized that
there was a mistake they flooded to the
gas station and wouldn't you know they
were totally willing to take advantage
of that 90 discounted gasoline i'm
surprised they didn't show up with
buckets and everything else they could
to store that gas because prices for
gasoline right now are record highs
especially over in california seven
dollars plus per gallon you'd think that
they would try to do all they could
but the problem is obviously that
nothing comes for free and this was a
small independently owned gas station
and ultimately there were about twenty
thousand dollars in losses that resulted
from all of this susanna said about this
quote
once i realized what was going on i
immediately thought we had been robbed
and i was scared that something terrible
had happened to the cashiers he was
unfortunately fired over this mistake
and he said about it quote even though
it cost me my job it's fine because the
truth is you know it was my fault so
he's definitely in good spirits over
this and you can't help but feel bad for
this guy everyone makes mistakes right
everyone types in the wrong number here
and there everyone will put in a typo
and for this guy it just happened to
result in twenty thousand dollars in
losses for his company now for most
people that's where the story would end
but in john's case it actually continued
because his sister felt so bad about it
that she decided to set up a gofundme uh
to help the newly unemployed john make
up the lost funds to his former employer
the gofundme was hugely successful it
surpassed the 20 000 mark that they were
trying to raise actually reaching and
surpassing 24 000
john's sister said about this quote he
doesn't have to pay it back but just the
fact that he is doing it and wants to do
it shows a lot of character and honesty
and responsibility and i'm really proud
of him for that you gotta wonder how can
this guy stay fired right like for one
this was an honest mistake which i
understand sometimes people can get
fired for honest mistakes honest
mistakes can kill people or they can as
in this case cost a company twenty
thousand dollars but then even after all
of that he didn't become a disgruntled
former employee like most people would
do in that circumstance no he raised the
money not to pay for his own living
expenses but to pay back his former
employer and then some right because he
actually raised twenty four thousand
dollars so if anyone deserves their job
back it's this guy maybe if he's not
able to get the job back at the gas
station i'll have to talk to david about
hiring him at the show because this is
exactly the type of commitment and
character that we want in an employee
here and if he makes another mistake if
he makes like a typo for us uh well it's
probably just going to result in a
youtube title being mislabeled and we'll
have to go in and fix it it's not going
to likely result in us losing twenty
thousand dollars so this is maybe not
the most important story but i thought
that with all this craziness surrounding
gas prices it would be an interesting
one to bring to your attention today my
pillow ceo mike lindell or as he's
better known mike pillow believes that
walmart is trying to cancel him because
they decided to pull his products from
their stores lindell was told on a zoom
call with walmart officials about two
weeks ago that the retailer would no
longer be selling my pillow in their
stores and would instead exclusively be
selling them on the walmart website so
that to me sounds like a half measure
because they're willing to sell this
product still just not in the retail
stores only in the online stores and i
think we can go further and maybe call
it a quarter measure because if the idea
is you want to disassociate with this
guy because he's become a controversial
figure well he's been that way for well
over a year now like it's been well over
a year since he's gone down the rabbit
hole of spewing election fraud
conspiracy theories and plenty of other
chains have already broken ties with him
like bad bath and beyond wayfair kohl's
they've all said we have we want nothing
to do with this guy so why is walmart
only now saying you know he's really
gone off the deep end we want to start
to cut ties with him well michael and
della is acting like this is a major
travesty and he went on lindell tv his
own tv broadcasting network to complain
about the whole thing it's been the same
rating if you're if that's what you're
talking about at walmart
uh forever we've been 10 years
and he and he goes you go and i said so
what does that do well we put this new
rating and you have to be at a four and
i go what do you when did you put this
in you ready everybody
he goes over two years ago
i said wait a minute so you put it in
over two years ago
and now you're saying you can't carry my
pillow two plus years later because of a
rating when we have sold 20 million
dollars or of my pillows a a year and
more maybe upwards of 40 million in your
store
and you're telling me that you put this
thing in two and a half years ago and i
said i get it you're canceling us
he had to smirk on his face and i
slammed the computer
disgusting shame on you walmart shame on
you
you know just because you thought you
could wait until now
for the american people for the people
of this country to sit there and do a
slow cancel out it's just as bad you
should have just done it on day one
when i uh when i stood up with the
evidence out there that's what they
should have done brandon you know
they're they're cowards they're
disgusting and uh
and you gotta love how the right wing in
this country are always so eager to use
their buzz words even when they don't
apply at all like the new one they've
been settling on recently is groomer
whenever we say that teachers should be
allowed to teach their students that gay
people exist in society and sometimes
men marry men and women marry women and
that's all well and good well the right
will call that grooming even though
obviously that term does not apply in
that situation it's the same with cancel
culture like walmart is not canceling
you mike lindell they're just making a
business decision that they think is
right for them and their consumers and
they have every right to do that it's
not canceling or anything like that and
when it comes to the voter fraud
narrative stuff that mike lindell loves
to push ever since this all started
after the 2020 election we've wondered
who actually believes this and who
doesn't believe this like rudy giuliani
for example sydney powell many of these
republican senators and congress people
i don't actually think that they believe
in the voter fraud stuff i think that
they're just paying lip service to it to
get on donald trump's good side mike
lindell on the other hand this guy
definitely believes it he has to believe
it i mean he had a decent enough
reputation before all this started
before he decided to hitch his wagon to
the trump train he had a successful
business going now his pillows are being
being taken out of stores all across
america and he's being sued by dominion
voting systems for well over a billion
dollars and you know he's had such a
fall from grace like he definitely
didn't have a material advantage to
doing this he definitely believes this
voter fraud stuff and it's sad to see in
a sense but maybe you can also say he
has what's coming to him all right
that's going to do it for today's
episode of the david pakman show i am
going to be hosting today's bonus show
as well so if you want to check that out
make sure to become a member or a patron
you can go to joinpacman.com or you can
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow and
sign up at the five dollar level to
everyone who's not going to be watching
the bonus show i'll see you next time i
do this and to all the members and
patrons you on the bonus show